At the Ford Motor Company, they're pretty proud of their F-150 trucks.
The F-series has been the best-selling truck in the U.S. for 47 years.
The best-selling vehicle of any kind in the U.S. for 42 years.
So what is it about this truck that keeps Americans coming back generation after generation?
Vox Adams just leased his second F-150.
I'm just going to stick with the truck because I bought a house.
I got to move furniture, got to do yard work, so I needed it.
I really like the interior on everything, whether it's from leather to just the cloth seating.
I have one with a big touchscreen, which is amazing.
Ford says customer feedback has helped continuously improve the vehicle since it was first made in 1948.
We know our customers better than anyone else.
We are constantly innovating with F-150.
And it's the technologies, it's the interior, you get into an interior,
and it's like a luxury vehicle.
You forget that you're in a truck.
At the Dearborn Michigan plant, trucks are continuously built by 5,200 employees working 10 hour shifts.
The final stages of the process include the engine checks, and then there's the body drop
where key pieces of the truck are married together.
The assembly process is checked by both computers and workers on the floor.
Humans and machines working in tandem to produce one new truck every 53 seconds.
You need people to build vehicles.
If you look at AI, if you look at all the technology that's coming out,
it's really about a collaborative space.
Every workstation has its own computer.
And it literally assists operator in the virtual station of making sure we ensure quality.
At the suburban fort of Sterling Heights in the Detroit area,
the F-150 accounts for about half of the dealership's business.
General manager Jim Elder drives one.
It fits my family's lifestyle, you know, I don't work in construction obviously,
but it helps me move bicycles if I have to pick something up for the house or tow something small or big.
You know, it handles my everyday needs.
Kevin Justima spent years in the auto industry,
and says Ford was the first to build a truck for the average person.
He says the company continues to innovate.
Ford's been in the market over a year now with the electric vehicle.
So it's just very much that leadership of innovation for the truck side
that makes over the 75 plus years makes people say,
oh, Ford's kind of a leader with their truck.
I trust this brand more.
Let me see what they have.
Justima and some reviewers point to poor fuel efficiency,
limited miles per gallon,
as a downside of owning one of these trucks.
But many Americans don't seem to mind.
Ford says it's made more than 41 million F-series vehicles
for U.S. customers since the truck's debut 76 years ago,
including almost 760,000 of them last year.
Dora McQuare, VOA News, Dear Born Michigan.